let's talk about the the new show
disjoint yes I was watching today is so
funny
you play the owner of a pot dispensary
yes and and tell us a little bit your
character is she's Ruth white better
vowel stone though
Ruth whitefeather Feldman I gotta get
this right yeah it's my first time
talking about yeah you work a lot so you
know yeah
so I play an owner of a dispensary I'm
very much into healing you know a view
marijuana that way and I have a son
who's actually been to business school
and he wants to turn it into Walmart
yeah so that's the conflict there but we
have so many other stories going on and
what's wonderful you will never have
seen a show like this I swear I swear to
you there are animations like when
somebody's stoned they have these
amazing animations that go into the
characters heads they are unethical Eva
below you're a believer also that in you
know your own personal beliefs so that
marijuana has helped a lot of people
yeah well here's the thing we had some
amazing NFL players called the gridiron
cannabis foundation we have fake ads on
the show that are fifties ads and
they're funny and stuff but for this one
we did something serious and these guys
belong to this foundation and they've
gotten off of the pharmaceuticals for
their brain injuries and they've
actually gone on to cannabis and it's
really helped them a lot I I'm not you
know I'm not an expert I've only done
research for my character and it's not
for everybody so I want to just you know
say that well so thank God it's for me
yeah
[Applause]
you're very diligent in your research
yeah well I try not to be too diligent
you